so what are in Chinese stock market rhop
9.1% in a single day not a stock the
market drops nine point one percent
single day on February 3rd 2020 after
the corona virus pandemic spreading all
over the place to the point where Apple
Microsoft Samsung Google Tesla all of
them have plants they have tens of
thousands of employees in China working
for them they sent everybody home they
shut them all down the province of Hebei
50 million people even live in there
they cannot leave the province I'm at a
Goldman Sachs meeting last week with the
chief investment officer she's on stage
talking about coronavirus everybody is
talking about this and how it affects
them so in today's episode we're gonna
talk about the pandemics in the past and
how many death tolls we've had the
different conspiracy theories we're
hearing about then how to market
responded six months later
twelve months later both in the US and
worldwide when a virus like this took
place in the past and how all of this
affect your finances so before I get
into it if this is your first time
visiting this channel just a normal
channel on YouTube for entrepreneurs if
you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel please do so there's hundreds of
videos on business hiring firing raising
money and many interesting interviews
that you can watch in the channel having
said that let's get right into it so
coronavirus what is it what type of a
virus is it coronavirus is a zoonotic
type transmitted between animals and
people the origins is from a city called
Wuhan which is a capital of who Bay
about 50 million people live there in
this province in China so now how does
this corona virus spread well it's
through confident sneezing it's through
close personal contact touching and
shaking hands or touching an object with
the virus on it then touching your nose
your mouth and your eyes and here's the
countries that are affected by this and
I keep this someone when I say countries
affected by this doesn't mean they've
had a person that died because so far
we've had 1500 there tolls from this
coronavirus but these countries have had
cases of corona virus such as US China
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia South Korea
Japan Taiwan Vietnam Singapore Australia
Belgium Cambodia Canada Egypt Finland
France Germany
in India Italy Malaysia Nepal
Philippines Russia Spain Sri Lanka
Sweden Thailand UAE and last but not
least UK now keep this part amount I'm
not going to get into what kind of a
virus this is because that's very
technical it'd be an hour video and
quite frankly I'm not a doctor to do
that I'm specifically talking about
effects of it worldwide and the economy
so now there's two words you hear about
epidemic pandemic the real difference
between epidemic and pandemic is
epidemic is more local pandemic is
global worldwide so if something spreads
within a nation maybe that's an epidemic
but if it starts going from US China
South Korea Japan now we're talking
about a pandemic pandemic is a form of
an epidemic is what it is right so now
pandemics what are the largest pandemics
we've ever had that have affected the
most people and cost the most lives I'll
go from top to bottom so at the top of
the black death which was between 1346
1353 somewhere between 75 to 200 million
people died now keep this in mind
obviously this is purely numbers that
have been passed down nothing is 100%
but this the data that you see when you
do some research
second one is flu a pandemic that was in
1918 around 20 to 50 million people died
HIV virus from 2005 to 2012 36 million
people died plague of Justinian which is
a Roman Empire 541 to 540 to 25 million
people died Phyllis Antonine plague
which was at a hundred sixty-five eighty
five million people died there then you
have the Asian flu in 1956 to 1958 two
million people died then you have flu
1968 a million third colera
which is 1852 to 1860 another million
then you have the Asiatic in Russia flu
from 1889 to 1890 which is another
million and last but not least is the
sixth cholera between 1910 1911 over
800,000 people done I keep this part of
mine every one of these you're looking
at is over 800,000 lives and it's third
world countries and it's pre pre 1968 I
know HIV is recent but pre 1968 so it
wasn't as advanced as it as it is today
and coronavirus so far is only 1500
document at that toll which is still a
big number you got to pay attention to
the biggest concern here's to make some
momentum doesn't take off and all of a
sudden it goes to a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand a million because that
really impacts a lot of people's lives
economy it
really affect a lot of different things
so let's compare SARS to coronavirus
SARS was originated in Beijing
coronavirus in Wuhan SARS pandemic was
an o2 o3 coronavirus was in 2020 China's
percentage of world GDP in oh 3 was only
8 point 7 percent but China today is 19
point three percent of world's GDP they
used to be the sixth largest economy
when stars took place today they're the
second largest economy why is this
important that's a very big difference
when you're eight point seven percent of
world GDP two 19.3 now you're the second
largest economy in the world so if
something happens to China everybody is
affected by because the only economy
above China's who us so this is why a
lot of industries are taking hits
whether it's travel manufacturing
shipping tech mobile you've seen cruise
ships where people stuck on a ship and
they can't go anywhere because they're
worried about the virus coming to them
you're hearing casino business Macau
Macau is a tourist place people go to
Macau regularly shut down so it's
affecting many different industries all
over the place now we're hearing a lot
of different conspiracy theories so the
first conspiracy theory you're hearing
about is from Tito Soto who is the
Senate President from Philippines and he
gets up and he shows this video this ten
minute video in front of about 150
decision-makers there and says this is
all the works of China China's using the
coronavirus as a way to weaponize
against its people right and there was a
big dispute we'll put the link before
you to watch it if you haven't seen it
yet some are saying Chinese government's
using this virus to attack innocent
people you're seeing a lot of folks that
are coming the government's coming in
pulling people throwing them into trucks
like quarantine you know to to get them
protect them from others saying this
could be an outbreak people are
screaming these videos are going viral
citizens of China are posting this
they're taking them down people are
getting arrested for no reason
so that's part of it were some are
saying that's one of the things that's
taking place some are saying US military
ci is directly involved you know another
one is China stole this virus from
Canada to weaponize it against its own
people russian TV host says it's trump's
fault a russian scientist says the u.s.
pharmaceutical companies behind us and
another expert says they're using this
as a way to target certain ethnicities
by the way there are hundreds of
conspiracies we can go through
that there's not really a virus going on
this is just a way to impose and control
people there's many of them okay many
many of them worthy of reading just to
kind of put it in a place in the back
your head but not into going deep into
it to believe 100% of everything people
are talking about because it'll drive
you nuts but the reason why I'm doing
this is because I'm hearing people talk
to me about it oh my gosh what about
this don't shake hands cover your mouth
when you're on a plane I'm always
traveling
you know Mario was just in a World War
II I do rocket are he's coming back from
Qatar he was at Maldives and Pat
everybody had masks on it was so
interesting seeing all these people
they're worried about it this is just
taking place right now the part I want
to talk about is how does this affect
the marketplace when it's taking place
because immediately when this happens a
lot of people panic let's see what
history tells us about what happened to
the stock market both with sp500 as well
as a Morgan Stanley Capital
International World Index which is
160,000 indexes worldwide to measure how
the world is doing world economy's doing
so if you look at this I'm not gonna
give you all the numbers you can go look
at the link below to study this for
yourself you're mainly looking for read
meaning the market dropped Green says
the market went up I'll give you the
list of pandemics which month it was
then six-month change in SMP 500
12-month change also an SMP 500 then
I'll give you 6 month for the MSCI how
to responded worldwide okay so HIV it's
read across the board six months later
point three twelve months later is
negative sixteen five and worldwide
affected by it as well then the rest of
it pneumonic plague it was affected by
the MSCI but not SMP SARS all positive
avian flu all positive donk fever all
positive
swine flu all positive colera all
positive burst all positive Ebola all
positive measles is pretty much even it
didn't really go up or down it affect a
little bit on twelve months but the MSCI
went up Zika all positive worldwide it
wasn't positive again measles in 2019
all positive you don't have 12 months
because it was just in June of 2019 so
when you're looking at it at the
beginning if people don't follow
finances and economy they think oh my
gosh it's the end of the world China
nine point one percent market drop what
could take place this is really gonna
affect me and this is why you
not be naive yourself you have to
consume the content that you're seeing
from everybody all the experts that
they're telling you then could do a
little bit of research like this for
yourself and I say maybe it's not as bad
as they're talking about what why are
you putting so much fear into me about
this because think about it this way
last year just a basic seasonal flu
seasonal flu that we get every year
500,000 people died last year just from
seasonal flu worldwide in the US alone
the numbers around 14,000 - I think
36,000 last year by the way this is the
part about China that this is why most
people don't trust the Chinese
government you know the Chinese
government said out of their 1.5 billion
people that live there in 2016 only 56
people died from the seasonal flu and in
2017 only 41 people died from a seasonal
flu and in 2019 144 that from seasonal
flu and they talk about their
unemployment it's only 3.2 percent the
last 20 years because the government
controls the data that they give to the
public you got to be naive to believe
whatever the Chinese government puts our
data wise because they're trying to
protect themselves to show to the world
that they're doing really really good of
course they had more people that died
from fluid than 56 and 2016 because
worldwide is 500,000 so again 500,000 is
here 1,500 is here is it really that
crazy to you know put all this content
online spend hundreds of hours on TV
we're putting that fear into you and I
I'm not telling you it's not worthy of
the content because we have to be aware
listen military slogan is very simple
stay alert stay alive if you're too
paranoid you can't enjoy anything about
your life because you're chill you
become an OCD about every single thing
now you can't really get the best out of
your life and enjoy it right so you look
at that part then the last thing I want
you to be thinking about is a final look
this ain't gonna be the first time or
the last time that they're gonna use
fear to control the populace keep this
part of mine how many people think are
gonna watch this video how many a half a
million maybe a million views maybe two
million three million maybe like the
us-china trade war video this case three
million views there's 7 billion people
living in the world you know for how
many centuries the government and people
of power and and mainstream media has
used fear to control the people do you
know for how long
powerful people have used fear tactics
to control the people for centuries and
it ain't never stopping the differences
today they have more
fools to do it and they're in your face
more notification notification
notification a notification fear fear
fear fear if you look over immobilized
but during the same entire time there's
a group of people that sit when they see
this taking place they sit there and say
don't over react military says staler
stay alive listen wash your hands
I will tell you that take care of your
body be careful how many times you're
touching your have a face keep washing
your hands if there's one thing that we
can get from this there's nothing wrong
with washing your hands 2030 times a day
if you can to protect yourself have
wipes with you have whatever you can
around you to take care of yes you got
to be taking care yes you got to stay
alert but you can't overreact if you
overreact you will take a hit you'll
have missed opportunities I did a video
a year ago talking about how to
capitalize up market crash you know
what's the first point I talked about
monetize fear not impose fear monetize
fear the government is gonna impose fear
the media is gonna impose fear that
doesn't mean you need to be controlled
by fear you need to stake and control
don't overreact
do your research watch this video I mean
obviously recovered coronavirus the
pandemics in the past SARS versus
coronavirus the different conspiracy
theories history-wise what it's done
market nine-percent seasonal flu half
the money you go to your own research
you don't don't take everything anybody
says and go you go to your research I'm
doing these things so you say I don't
know about that let me go do my own
research great as you become smarter and
smarter and smarter then you make better
moves in times like this so you end up
winning both financially by educating
the people around you your loved ones
your family and your not controlled by
the media and the government when they
impose fear on you so having said that
if you enjoyed today's video I got two
other videos I want you to watch one of
them is an interview I did with Ray
Dalio
we talked a lot about China if the topic
of China interests you obviously Ray
Dalio is worth 19 billion dollars he
didn't get to 19 billion dollars but not
known what to do the guy's a genius if
you haven't watch this video go watch
this video and the other video I want
you to watch is the us-china trade war
that I put out that on how long ago was
if you haven't watch it click on this
one as well it's very very technical
detail on why the conflict was taking
place and it has a lot to do with
today's video that we talked about so if
you want to watch great value click here
if you want to watch us-china trade war
click here and if you haven't subscribed
to the channel yet
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
[Music]